welche öffnungen können jetzt schnell
kommen gibt ja bald wieder im pk herr
kubicki
zweig plus ist unsinn denn noch einmal
zweig bedeutet die beute müssen alle
gebens sein und zwei gibt deutliche
schützt jetzt wieder vorgegeben was ja
angeht ist der open comeback schon
keinen sinn mehr also das ist nonsens
gelesen thema bei der nächsten ecke raus
damit das weiß ich wäre eine meiner
forderung mit wir können auch zweig
waren einkaufen bett lassen wenn wir wir
wissen ja dass meinte dann im
lebensleistung ist so gar keinen
infektionsketten gekommen ist warum die
lotter masken getragen abstand gehalten
das können sie neben anderen geschäft
genau gestellt genauso organisieren also
dass während der nächste punkt und ich
würde immer noch empfehlen persönlich
zum selbstschutz jeweils einen
geschlossenen räumen oder in bonn oder
s-bahn in der p2 maske zu tragen weil
das mit sicherheit ein riesen schutz
gegen die infektion